thank you to skillshare for being the
sponsor of this video
one of the topics that i'm really
passionate about is slight writing and
slide writing is the science or the art
of creating slide presentations
in the style of leading consulting firms
like mbb
and this is mckinsey bcg and bane as you
probably already know if you're a
regular watcher of this channel i worked
at mckinsey for six years
i taught slight writing inside the
firm's two junior colleagues but i'm
also giving trainings on slide writing
to corporations and also serve as a
lecturer
on communication and slide writing for
instance at the university of zangala
and mba program
so today i will help you to build your
slide writing skills as well and i will
do this by reviewing slide presentations
that you sent me so i asked you on
instagram to send me some of the
documents that you're working on for
instance from university projects and i
received several submissions from you so
we're going to look into this in a
moment but before we do that i just want
to be
really clear on one thing so maybe some
of you are asking yourselves now
where did all my hair go and due to the
special situation in germany
all the hairdressers are closed at the
moment so no
i did not bribe any professional to cut
my hair
i just asked my sister to do it and if
you follow me on instagram you know
exactly what happens and you also know
why this
maybe was not the best idea but let's
not talk more about this right now
welcome to another coffee break here on
my channel from learning it's already
pretty late here in germany so i'm
drinking tea
please help yourself to a cup as well
but now without further ado
let's jump in so i'm looking now at the
screen in front of me where open several
of the presentations that you sent me so
of course you won't go over every
presentation slide by slide but i always
selected a couple of slides that i
believe will be most educational to
discuss
so just bear in here with me i trust
there are some very very important and
valuable slide writing lessons that we
will not jointly identify and find while
looking at these pages
and here let's start with this one this
seems to be some type of university
presentation about an economics class
the
turkish growth miracle so frank have no
idea about the topic so let's just
look at this page what do we see here so
my first impression is that this page
looks kind of messy but of course the
question is why does it look messy what
makes this page look messy and if you
look into this probably the main reason
is that this page uses all kinds of
different
font sizes and this is really a problem
that you see quite often so let's look
here of course the action title
28 here this title 24 red curve
depreciation 18 this 120
this one 18 18 here in the chart
12 but here also in the chart 18 so it's
really all over the place and i believe
this
really significantly adds to this
unclean
to this weird unorganized look so the
key rule that you always want to follow
when doing these types of presentations
that the body of your slide
so everything except for the title maybe
some footnotes
should be the same font size so now
let's look at the chart let's look at
how this
chart is created and the first thing
that pops into my eye are these very
thick dotted lines so usually if you
make dotted lines you don't want them to
be so dominant you want them to be light
and in the background but here because
these are one of the thickest lines in
this chart they're very dominant right
and this just doesn't look right
next is here the different colors so
this is a green line a red line a blue
line
the general rule is that whenever you
use colors on your page it either has a
direct meaning
or there needs to be a legend and again
this will look cleaner
nicer more sophisticated my last comment
is just switching here between these two
slides so what you see here is that
several elements are
jittering are moving this is also
something you want to avoid so
let's look at the action type you see
this is moving this means that this
isn't nicely and properly aligned and of
course this will be noticed if you save
this as a pdf or whatever and you just
scroll through it and you see all these
elements moving from page to page this
just
looks not aligned not professional the
same of course here also with the text
with
these bullets and same thing here with
the footer why is this moving again make
sure that you have no
gearing on your pages this just looks
unprofessional next presentation so this
is apparently a deck about
rockefeller so some information some
facts on him and here my first
impression is that this
does already look a bit more organized a
bit more clean than the slides that we
saw before and if you look at this you
can
see some good slide writing principles
followed here and if you're more
interested in that because i cannot now
go into every little piece of that
i actually created a whole course on
slide writing on how to create
powerpoint presentations in the style of
leading consulting firms so if you're
interested to that and want to learn
more check out the link in the video
description
have over 10 000 students taking the
course i trust that
might be interesting for some of you now
i want to focus on this specific page
and again it looks not too bad so it has
a proper action title
or the text here is of the same text
size so one thing that you could do to
further improve is add
separator lines so for some reason this
still looks a bit unfinished to me it
seems like something is
missing here on this page and i believe
one thing is these separator lines that
you could include between these elements
to make it look a bit more organized
then the next question is also
so what exactly is this so these
elements are introduced here what
elements are these exactly what
am i looking at right now what is the
title or the organizing principle of
these elements so if i understand this
correctly also from inferring it from
the action title this is probably
something like the competitive
advantages that rockefeller had or the
things that he did the measures that he
undertook to increase its market share
and if this is what it is then also add
this as a little subtitle
here just to make it more clean next one
let's look at the chart
and again here basic slide writing
principles are
followed the one thing that i want to
give you as a general tip and this is
that whenever you use percentages
always add the percentage of what
are you looking at the percentage of
what one question that you could
potentially ask yourself when you look
at the market share is that whether this
is the market share measured in
units or the market share measured in
u.s dollar
so this here just remains unclear and
this could be easily fixed just by
making yourself a habit of always
writing percentage of
what so of the market units or the
market in dollars so let's move to the
next presentation this looks like some
type of
business pitch of a product which seems
to be a chair
that is included in a backpack so
interesting idea for sure again let's
just pick one slide to this one let's
just focus on this and this apparently
is the page in this document where the
market and industry for this product is
supposed to be explained so here the
first thing that you see is that it's
really hard to understand what the
message of all of this really is
supposed to be
what is not really the thing that i
should take away from this page and here
the clearest
thing that is missing is the action
title so you see the title is just
market and industry this is pretty much
just a header but a clear action title
is missing and this is exactly why it's
just
super difficult to really understand
what the message is if you have no idea
what i'm talking about if you don't know
what an action title is then check out
my video that i made specifically on
action titles where i explain
what it's all about action titles are
fundamental piece of
every slide presentation check out the
video here to learn more about it where
discussed this in the past and now if
you look into this you see again
different font sizes used this is font
20 this is font 18.
of course this here is something that
you can barely read neither general
rulers especially for professional
presentations never just copy paste
charts like that but especially if you
already have the numbers as they already
apparently present here
just recreate the chart in powerpoint it
will always look much better and much
cleaner but here's so much remains in
the dark so
pains of the industry what industry
exactly are you talking about here so
this
the sports and outdoor market is this
the industry
as far as i can see this was also not
properly introduced on the pages before
so really hard to understand same thing
here for this chart so what exactly is
this chart supposed to tell me so
understand that here below there's some
type of market sizing for the portuguese
market
but here this chart has user penetration
worldwide so the user penetration of
what and here as far as i understand
portugal seems to have a rather low to
medium user penetration so what does
this mean is this good is this bad
so again i really have no idea at all
what this page is supposed to tell me
what i'm supposed to take out of this
page so our next presentation this is a
set of slides that apparently talk about
networking
and overall i must say they look
professional they look very well done
one thing though i just want to put your
attention is that on a page like that
there is just
lots of text and in almost all
situations
people will never read this much text
even if they get this handed as a report
or handed as a business presentation
this is just something that will not be
read what you could easily do here is
just to de-word the whole page so take
out lots of words by keeping the full
meaning of what you see here because
indeed
your full sentences are used as if you
would
read a book so on these live
presentations you usually want to say
as much as possible with as little words
as possible
just to declutter it to deword it and
the main way to do this is of course
rather use bullet point style instead of
full sentences so just one little
example instead of writing the
value of this information depends on the
trust within the network
just write a bullet saying information
value depends on network trust so one
little thing that you can often do to
take out words is to delete articles
like the
to dework the page and indeed another
way to improve your communication and
business skills is to take classes on a
platform like skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of classes for
creative and curious people you can
explore new skills
deepen your passions and get lost in
creativity there are classes on
marketing personal branding presentation
skills and many more all of these are
topics that are highly applicable to a
career in consulting
banking or corporate and the best thing
is that i made a slight writing class
for skillshare so you can access and
enjoy it as a skillshare member
personally i recently took the class
productivity masterclass
principles and tools to boost your
productivity from the fellow youtuber
ali abdal it's a great class it taught
me many new aspects of productivity and
i very much enjoyed how you applied the
pareto principle or the 80 20 rule to
productivity
classes on skillshare are specifically
curated for learning there are no ads
they're always launching new premium
classes so you can stay
focused and follow wherever your
creativity takes you and the best thing
is that it's
less than ten dollars a month with an
annual subscription
skillshare created a special offer for
subscribers of this channel film
learning and so the first
thousand subscribers of me click on the
skillshare link in the video description
we get a free trial of the skillshare
premium membership i hope this helps you
to explore your creativity
check it out link in the video
description so now to the next
presentation here the one thing that i
want to point out is how
too much graphical things how too many
animations
can really take away from the content of
the slides and can
even also look unprofessional to some
extent so here if you go over there are
so
many animations so many colors that do
not really add much
to the actual content to the actual
meaning that the things that you
actually want to say with your slides
get completely
diminished so here just be sure that you
use graphical elements like this and
bold colors like this
very very selectively usually less
is more and the same is true for
animations usually there are no
animations and presentations like this
one of the reasons being that often
these presentations are not even getting
presented but they're just printed out
as documents and then you just go over
these documents in a meeting and
everybody just has a handout of this
presentation document in front of him or
her but even if you are presenting it
on a display animations is just not the
look and feel that you should go for for
c-level presentations it will be
perceived as unprofessional
this is just not what is expected from
you in these environments so now next
one and again this seems to be from a
university project and the reason why
included is just because i wanted to
show you the bit different
type of style that this presentation is
using this is a presentation style that
you will see
more frequently in banking so in most
consulting contexts
pages like that would never go into the
main deck
just far too much text things like this
would go
in the backer but for whatever reason
bankers just like to put even more words
in their presentations than consultants
but this
is indeed what you will find if you join
a bank and just want to also make aware
of one other specialty that you often
find in these banking presentations
and this is the so-called football field
chart and this is exactly what you see
here bankers use this all the time to
display spreads and company valuations
coming from different valuation types
but the problem is
nobody understands this outside of
banking i tried to make charts like this
several times
in a consulting context and i've yet to
meet a client
that can understand and read this type
of chart so my takeaway here is that
there are some differences in consulting
compared to banking presentations though
i would argue if you
want to learn the presentation style
that will make you successful
in c-level environments in boardroom
environments of large corporate firms
then i'd argue that the consulting style
probably will be a bit more successful
for you
this is at least from my experience what
works much better if you want to
communicate your insights to your
leadership
in most business situations and
environments i hope you found this
helpful and i want to say a big thank
you to everybody who volunteered to send
me their presentations here for review
in this video this of course is much
appreciated and i hope
there were some learnings for many of
you out there but of course i also want
to be clear that there is no such
thing as the law of slide presentations
right so after all everything that i
said you is from my personal opinion of
course if you ask other people they
might have a different opinion and of
course if you see something differently
very happy to discuss this with you just
leave me a comment below in the comment
section
very happy to interact here with you and
also to learn from you
from your perspective and your
experiences now if you took any value
out of this video at all please hit the
like button for the youtube algorithm
and also subscribe to the channel to
stay up to date on all the content
if you want to see even more from me
follow me on instagram my handle is firm
learning i also have a mailing list you
can sign up via the link in the video
description thanks again to skillshare
for being the sponsor of this video
there is a link to skillshare in the
video description and i can only
encourage you to make use of the free
trial that is provided there in addition
to that as always of course a big thank
you to all the members of firm learning
as well you are the ogs you're really
supporting here the course on from
learning so thank you so much
my name is heinrich i'm releasing videos
every single week on saturday here on my
channel from learning so looking forward
to see you again next week
until then good weekend to all of you
keep learning
cheers heiner here